can i tell you something that happened
to me i i haven't told anybody this
never happened to me before i was
outside of a 7-eleven in austin i'm not
going to say which one and there was a
gentleman
that approached me
this is at three or four at night which
is usually when i go uh i program all
night and i just like to go and take a
break
he approached me in the way that maybe
somebody who recognized me approached me
he did a double take he
walked past me and then walked back
and then looked at me and i went into
7-eleven i thought that's weird uh
and then i i came out with my slushie
and
and then
he approached me
and he said can i give you a [ __ ]
so i have never
no really yeah so the energy he put i've
never had were you wearing a suit no
okay i was wearing like uh
the sweatpants and i was very kind of
like hiding from the world yeah yeah
type of thing i've never had anybody
approach me that way but the energy he
put the love he had in the approach i
thought he'd be like um
love you on rogan yeah i love you
something like love some kind of and
then he just said can i i'm forgetting
the exact wording because it wasn't
uh the wording was such that he wasn't
he wanted to make me happy ah he didn't
want to make himself happy you want to
make me happy well when i forgot can i
give you a [ __ ] i think that was the
thing
because if you said can you give me a
[ __ ] it would be it would be very
different yeah yeah yeah no but i think
there's more aggressive way of phrasing
that but he he presented himself see i
forget because it was almost like gentle
and poetic and i was like
i i just stuttered and said no no thank
you
that's what everyone does
yeah it's no thank you to
no no no no no no thank you in my mind i
was like is this a threat
because it's fortnite ah i wasn't
exactly sure i mean i've never
experienced this i imagine this is what
sort of um women often experience that
kind of the danger the constant threats
all around you but i've never that's
just it was uh it was a funny little
moment i i didn't know what to do with
it
yeah that happened and i
i uh go to that 7-eleven often looking
for the guy
because now all right now i would say
yes no there you there used to be a
steam room in beverly on beverly
boulevard and um
my brother and i walked in there once
and i
we walked in and was a man sitting there
erection
and his dick was so big he was jerking
it off with both hands
and we kind of walked in and he goes
what's up and he just did it
and we just sat there you know i mean
because it was not aggressive
yeah yeah yeah maybe that was the same
feel you sense that it wasn't an
aggressive thing yeah it wasn't yeah
yeah it was just a kind it was he was
just minding his own business he threw
it out
but it wasn't also
it wasn't sexual either it was like
it was like it's just you know it's just
like it's like love or something yeah i
felt like he it's almost like can i give
you a hug
right then why don't you just take it i
i keep looking for it next time i see it
it's not in a gay world yeah yeah
you